hey twig you wanna help us get on here
this time I need you to get the thing I
wore my hands
we told you it was this big that's my
underwear conquer let's just agree to
never discuss this going into the galaxy
volume 2
hope you're ready it'll be here any
minute is that a rifle you know what a
rifle looks like it's just sort where
your thing and gun for mine but I guess
we're both doing guns now I just didn't
know that that's intense
I see it within you there jealousy
betrayal
is it argues to cleanse the universe of
between man
you know they told me you people were
conceited douchebags but that isn't true
at all
dude I'm using my wrong eyes put your
seatbelt on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so with saving the galaxy average we're
really gonna be able to jack up a price
if with two-time galaxy Davis
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
sometimes the thing you're searching for
your whole life
it's right there by your side all wrong
you're right
[Music]
family
so many
after all these years I've found you and
who the hell are you I'm your dad Peter
[Music]
you